it is a great story for parents but also
children gather round multi-generational
family
because we've got a kid who loves sesame
street in the room he's going to love
this
take a listen
if you have little ones or you've been
alive in the last 40 years you will
recognize immediately what you just saw
that is sesame workshop
they are launching a new picture book
with some very important lessons in it
it's called
heroes wear masks elmo's super adventure
vlad duty got a first look for our
school matters series from a very
well-placed insider vlad good morning to
you
good morning guys by the way tony elmo
is still living at home uh
there are certainly a lot of changes
being made to classrooms across the
country to keep children safe
and this new book is filled with tips
from elmo
to help kids who are a little nervous as
they navigate this new normal
only on cbs this morning i recently had
the privilege
of sitting down with our furry red
friend
and i was kind of nervous about going
back to school
emma's mommy and daddy taught emma how
do belly breaths
to calm down when elmo has big feelings
like this you breathe in
and you breathe out i think it almost
feel a lot better
yeah that that seems to work for me too
um so so what's different about school
this year for you
elmo's not unable to hug his friends or
give them high fives
so we rave to each other instead oh and
our seats are far apart
but elmo still can see his friends do
you wear a mask elmo
yes emma is a master in school and
anytime
elmo goes outside it's very important
yeah wearing a mask helps everybody stay
healthy
elmo wants all kids to stay safe and
healthy
as they start their school year
[Music]
another reassuring message from sesame
street during a time
kids need it most hi hello anthony how
are you
i'm good can you help me just like the
one big bird shared with our own anthony
mason back in april
in the early days of quarantine there's
some kids out there big bird
who might be who might be feeling scared
or lonely right now
what would you say to them we can lend a
hand or or a wing in my case
and we can help each other and you can
you can send somebody a virtual hug
how about that he was a big venture well
hug from elmer
virtual hugs or waving to your friends
in school
and to help kids ease into that new
normal elmo and his friends have a new
picture book called
heroes wear masks elmo's super adventure
that's elmo wearing a mask as he is
super ready for school
that's the new classroom where elmo is
excited to see his friends
even though they have to sit far apart
and of course
reminding everyone to wash hands
frequently
parents need to ease their own
anxiety because children are watching us
child development expert dr rosemary
trulillo is senior vice president for
curriculum and content at sesame
workshop
we need to talk to our children about
how the class is going to be different
and how we are going to be wearing our
masks in school and how the desks are
going to be
set apart so they know what to expect so
it won't be surprising to them were you
nervous about going back to school
which brings us back to my virtual chat
with elmo
and this valuable piece of advice he
shared for
all of us most important is to be extra
extra careful and extra safe and that
helps elmo feel better too
and then elma does the belly breathing
and the two of those things together
make you feel a lot better
i've interviewed prime ministers
presidents and celebrities but this was
a very fun interview talking to elmo
guys something we can all learn
elmo says he and his friends do that
belly breathing every morning
because it's a nice thing to start the
day yeah heroes wear masks almost super
adventure comes out on september 15th
really good stuff fantastic yeah yeah i
like that elmo's also working from home
like the rest of it
you know he looks a little different
vlad he's not as scruffy as he usually
is and he's reading a little purple
these days
oh that's just our monitor
something about elmo that just takes
care of it
thank you very much and thank you elmo